vsauce michael here coming to you today
from a hotel in amsterdam i'm speaking
at the youtube roadshow here on friday
and jake and i just got in this morning
but i couldn't resist
i'm putting this video together before i
go to bed i've got travel info and some
things you could do online now guys it's
dong metria life first on the plane over
here i found that the bathroom does not
allow you to flush squares triangles or
circles but that was okay because
luckily i poof trapezoids next Jake and
I brushed up on our Dutch history here
is an original Rembrandt very beautiful
and very much a guy with his head cut
open so his brain can be played with it
might seem gross but it's doing stuff
like that that put their physicians
centuries ahead of their time oh look
here's Jake waiting for a Chinese
massage just kidding what he really
wants is a dong Fang these are some
leather shoes found buried in Amsterdam
worn more than 600 years ago and these
are my sweet new kicks as well as
Amsterdam's very last execution blade
actually used for cutting people's heads
off in public from the mid 1700s now
that's too much cool down with some
interactive illusion sites sites like
these allow you to see how perception
tricks work for instance squares getting
darker based on their surroundings even
if they actually match now this is one
of my favorites you can check out things
like the famous tabletop illusion both
tabletops are the exact same shape don't
believe me we'll click show me the site
also has parallel lines you can warp as
well as my favorite this color and this
color look like blue and yellow but they
are the exact same your brain plays
tricks on you by determining what color
it thinks it's looking at by looking at
context and surroundings even though the
light hitting your retina is gray in
both cases now be sure to check out this
other site where for instance you can
investigate Dolly's naked woman painting
that from far away is Abraham Lincoln
seriously mouse-over the painting to
blur it and see the truth back to
Amsterdam here is a hog slaughtered in
the open and some kids making a fun toy
balloon out of its bladder
tomorrow I'm going to go out and see
where I can get my very own big piece
Akbar but until then be sure to check
out this site suggested by cook Buchan
you may have seen it before but it takes
a sentence you write and finds popular
song lyrics to say it for you it doesn't
have enough words yet so be sure to help
out and contribute let me show you an
example
[Music]
keep the suggestions coming I've already
got a lot of youtube messages full of
great stuff from you guys that I can't
wait to share I'm gonna be a little bit
busy in the next few days but be sure to
subscribe to Vsauce if you're awesome
and how can I forget this Jake I
couldn't help but notice that your
coffee is a lot smaller than mine oh
yeah I think it's the girly way